(typing)
- Guys, before we
start not working,
I've been ordered by
Human Resources to give
an orientation on
sexual harassment.
(Christine groans)
- Damn it, Lyle, did
you tell the day shift
you got molested again?
- I felt a tingling in my sleep.
- You just have
poor circulation.
- Wish my ass got molested.
Last time a man touched me
it involved a Greyhound bus
breaking down and a shoehorn.
Use your imagination.
He put the shoehorn in my pussy.
♪ Oh, we got it made
♪ Yeah, nothin's
gonna get us down
♪ Everything's perfect
♪ 'Cause baby we got it made
- It could be good, guys.
Maybe I can finally find out
what Fallopian tubes are.
I think it's british for trains.
- There's a way to be
friendly and professional.
HR wants me to
demonstrate appropriate
workplace conversation.
Here we go.
Hey, Christine,
how's your day going?
- Oh, you know,
here so, not good.
(chuckles)
- Sounds zany.
So, ez equals, do you
still not wanna come over
and watch Showgirls with me?
I got dip.
- No.
- Is it 'cause you're
afraid to get hurt?
- No.
- Are you anxious
'cause you have a kid
and you're nervous I'd
think that's gross?
- No.
- Is it you not me?
- It's you.
- I was joking when I asked
if you had an OxyContin guy.
- You ain't got game for shit!
- Hey, can't you just be one
of those fun black ladies
that helps me get
my groove back?
- Girl from Tuesday not
returning your phone calls?
- Yeah.
- Same one who gave you
an over-the-pants hand job
at Dave and Buster's?
- Had a grip like a worker elf
and her hair
smelled like autumn.
- Uh, Richie?
- Hey, when I stare
dramatically into the distance,
you let me stare dramatically
into the distance!
That's Richie's time!
(upbeat tune)
Now we're gonna find
out what's a good touch
and what's a bad touch.
Elmer, get up here.
Touch him.
- [Lyle] Bad touch.
- How Lyle?
- Some people erogenous zones
are in their upper body.
- Thank you, Lyle, for another
terrible episode of Real Sex.
Anita?
- Bad touch.
- Good touch.
If it's a girl doing it it's
not wrong, it's just hot.
- Anybody got any melted
butter and semitones?
Last motherfucker who hit
this shit was J. D. Salinger.
- For once,
for once can we be appropriate?
You're all unprofessional, rude,
and honestly you smell awful.
I know that doesn't have
to do with the other two,
but I felt I really
needed to say it.
- She's right.
- Thank you.
- If you guys wanna
sexually harass someone,
you do it on the subway
like a normal person.
- Mhm.
- I guess that's progress.
(fan clunks on)
- Oh, I just got molested again.
- It was the fan, Lyle.
- That's what that was?
(laughing)
Oh, man.
And those rides my
next door neighbor
Terry gave me in fifth grade
where he hid the Tic Tac
somewhere in his pocket
but I could never find it,
that was the fan too, right?
- Uh, yeah.
- Won't be needing
this whistle no more.
(whistle blows)
- I know that this whistle is
primarily used to stop rape,
but that was pretty
close to chumbawamba.
♪ We got it made
♪ Yeah, nothing's
gonna get us down
♪ Everything's perfect